hello rose hi hey ro hey Pat what's up
sit there you go hi Josh welcome back
got a pet barrier Perry's coming up here
now his there we were actually just
talking about this during the break is
there is there any a competition between
you two is it difficult when like it's
it's a husband and wife and right now
you know the wife is a title holder you
guys both do or have done the same thing
I think competition makes us stronger
yeah competition in a good way Yeah
right but there's no jealousy like when
comedians dates there's always that one
thing we are kind of happy for each
other but then there's that whole like
right like which one of us is really
poppin off right now yeah yeah so
there's a bit gets a bit competitive
yeah he used to yell at me to say faster
faster I'm like with the wrong guy my
aunt I'd come up with excuses so yeah
it's kind of healthy to not have it I
guess cuz with with commonism but the
difference is with fighters like you you
you know you're you're fighting and
you're not fighting anymore so it's like
it's kind of hard to you know if you're
not actively fighting it's you know you
know get competitive about it no it's
terrible
it's awful I want to people ask me all
the time if I'm ever gonna fight again
the answer is always gonna be yes as
soon as as soon as possible but do you
miss it yeah absolutely you do every day
what do you miss about it just all of it
just the whole become the the
competition the game of the game of
fighting the game of fighting is is the
part that you miss the most is standing
in that arena where you did you see the
last fight yeah this is just standing in
that arena walking out to that arena to
a UFC fight whether you're the main
event or you're the first fight of the
night there's enough
like it there's like a fought I fought
everywhere man there's nothing like
walking out to a UFC fight and being in
that arena being in that octagon matched
up with somebody else's there's nothing
your name across the whole arena oh you
you actually do look up and take it in a
little bit sometimes there are certain
fights where I do and they're certain
fights where I don't I wish I could have
gone back to the first you know when I
got the title
I really just take it in for a second
but they rushed us out of there real
quick oh you just kind of stand there
and soak it in I mean well at the time
no because I was just like what just
happened like like it's I described it
as I felt like I robbed a bank almost at
that that night and I just wanted to get
home just because the whole week in the
build-up was crazy but you know looking
back on it when when GSP won the title
that night he was just kind of like in
the rain just like you know I think just
the experience and you know being away
from the sport for so long but you know
coming back maybe he knew to take it in
a little bit more didn't at all no soon
as soon as the punch line is the first
fight everybody kind of checked out like
you a little stunned and what happens he
just didn't kind of go inside and shut
the blinds and yeah I mean if you were
sitting there an extra minute okay but
you know you went back at it again and
you enjoyed it you know yeah people who
enjoy it too much might not do it again
and again you know could they're just
enjoying the moment too much so you have
to win again to enjoy the moment you
have to carry the belt everywhere with
you now that's why the one annoying
about the championship
yeah they pin the belt on you that's
where they tag they don't pin the belt
on your [ __ ] mittens what a
non-fighting idiot about having like
some suspenders on the boat just like
wearing like what how do you actually
put it on and just walk around look at
yourself in it or do you just kind of
hold that sometimes yeah at home if I'm
like you know if I'm feeling myself just
like be cleaning the house and be like
you know I'm gonna take the belt out
yeah we usually but most of the time it
just saves in the closet it does yeah so
your visibility is really high now is it
yeah it's very different from where you
were like say a year ago or two years
ago
yeah yeah comfortable for you yeah
because I think the way that I carry
myself I think try and say as regular as
possible so you know people don't people
treat me regular as as much as possible
I mean I think that a lot of people are
people have been overall very respectful
there has been a few people where it's
like okay I'm just trying to like sit in
my backyard man like like that's super
inappropriate but like what are they do
in your backyard if people drive by and
stop their cars in the middle of street
and run over a couple times yeah people
know where we live
and what do they say holy [ __ ] is it you
hey man I don't mean to bother you I
don't mean to and then they want to know
I usually sometimes I like run to run to
the gym and people like stop on the
street or like honk dirt you know honk
their horn and be like you know like
that's cool boiling and I'm if I'm just
trying to enjoy myself knocking
someone's door psychotic yeah yeah
google map it I didn't mean to bother
you but I put this in my GPS of course
you do I hope this isn't weird but I
found your dress I'm on your door I'm
sorry yeah you don't just look up on a
champions house you know where you're
going yeah so yeah that's it that's very
invasive it's been great it has been
it's been great because no one's been I
don't know roses as a believer that if
you put your sunglasses on and you try
to get everyone to stay away from you
that's why people start running towards
you and just screaming last night by
being by being just rose and being and
carrying yourself and normal just
regular way people are being they're
being very respectful like so when we do
walk in places you can see you can see
you can hear the mic drop but no one's
running over like people just like
that's the champ right there holy [ __ ]
is it is the pressure different like now
that there's more expectations on you
when you step into the Octagon like
people expect and
more people have higher expectations of
you and that goes along with being the
champion do you feel that or can you
block that out I feel it but I don't let
it penetrate my bubble you know because
once you first off I try not to even
expect anything myself because I feel
like that just set you up for
disappointment in general and life so
you shouldn't expect nothing but also
other people's expectations on you man
that's like that's even like you know
double works cuz it's just people
usually what other people think isn't
you know they're they don't they don't
walk in your shoes so it's it's probably
off or it's probably wrong so I try and
try and just concern myself with what I
think and and keep it to that and then
yeah I do feel that there's there's more
things that can distract you more the
higher up you climb there's more
pitfalls and traps and things that
you're like damn why was I even wasting
my time thinking about this you know
like you kind of catch yourself in
little little sneaky traps what's a trap
what would you consider a trap or
something that you didn't see coming um
well for example new sunglasses at night
yeah definitely you know managing your
money well that's important one but then
also like just little things like
getting distract like the one of the
first things that I learned about this
last training camp in the beginning of
it there's little ego like your ego is
bigger just because of what you've
accomplished but then you step into the
real world and it's like sometimes I
don't always translate and so you kind
of just you know set yourself but like
your ego pulls like distracts you and
pulls you into like dumb things that you
you shouldn't get pulled into you think
about the ego this last training camp
started off you know I totally we had
almost forgot about this like this last
training camp started off with rows not
feeling too confident in herself so we
spent the first few weeks telling her
about how she's the best at everything
and recording every practice and letting
her see every practice you're so good at
everything then it went from not feeling
so confident to almost feeling
overconfident like yeah I'm the best in
the world so we had to shut that down
like three weeks into it were like okay
no more complimenting rows no more
telling her that she's the best you
didn't tell her this though you just not
among each other the three coaches that
we all told we all
that so we kind of like it went from
yeah I don't know about build her up and
then and then kind of like just just
leave it like don't let's not tell her
how that she's the best let's not let's
not compliment so much well that went on
and they got like right Iran's like
maybe two weeks before the fight and
Rose was feeling very negative and we
totally forgot that we made it a point
to make them feel very negative but why
is she walking around and then Tony
remember he's like oh wait a minute that
was the plan was to break her down we
totally forgot that we didn't bridge so
we spent like six weeks on man you're
never gonna make it
yeah one of the one of the first little
distractions that my ego almost pulled
me into I was doing like like laps and
there's like this big long grassy field
and our you know behind our house
whatever so I was doing laps and like
doing sprints or whatever in the grass
and there's a in there's a school back
there and there's you know kids were at
recess so I don't think the like the
kids had no idea what I was doing and
they were like they were kind of like
yeah I felt like it was making fun of me
like look at her how she's running or
something you know like kind of mocking
me I was like and I just like started
getting distracted by it it's like why
am I even concerned with these little
kids yeah yeah of course they just make
funny anybody that's like not in school
so anyway but yeah it's just like little
stuff like that's like man that little
do they know that I'm the champion of
the world that's school [ __ ] just being
made fun of by the training camps that
you know there's that much psychology
yeah you guys become like and there were
lessons so like and there's like little
lessons that are being learned
throughout the entire training camp and
one of the so I write it on the board
like if I you know take a lesson so one
of the first things was ego ego as a
distraction will pull you into dumb [ __ ]
you know so and then it was for real
like just the entire training camp
there's little things like
that like trying to think go in another
scenario oh I was somebody was of like
recorded this remember on the plane that
was pretty bad
so it was like almost a reminder to ten
like bring me back to you know like to
humble myself before I got to the fight
cuz and I was feeling pretty like okay
about myself and I got on the plane and
I don't know like you tell this story
pretty like better but I'm a guy no no
the when they were about to announce
like oh yeah we'll get on the plane now
we're all like 27 27 see or something
like that right so we're walking and
we're waiting halfway down the plane I'm
already sitting down roses still
standing there and the announcement come
on lady says alright we've closed the
cabin door yada yada this and that in
the bat would you like to let everyone
know in the back of the plane we've got
and she's in the back of the plane we've
got rows like well that was he must be
trying to my like we've got rose and
Kevin servers you in the back that's
when you guys are going like okay we got
to break her down we're on the way to
New York man she's like in the backup
plane we've got rose and she froze
service you in the back of the plane
than fake humility when it's unwarranted
[Laughter]
[ __ ] is that lady waving and everybody
she's gonna be a problem on the way to
New York with that mental preparation is
just insane I love that you guys forgot
straight team meeting we had a team
meeting about we had a complete team
meeting about why is Rose feeling so
negative likewise yo man this is not
turning on like what is going on with
her and Tony Raines like oh yeah we're
supposed to make her feel bad like that
was the get in like we Trevor and I both
paused and we couldn't figure out what
the game plan was was to build her up
but then we build her up way too much so
we had to break her down a little bit
yes just something just because with
when it comes to Rose it's always mental
it's nothing it's not the physical is
always gonna be there but it's it's
always a mental training camp and yeah
we had we dropped you had to try to keep
it even you know what I mean
you have the potential to be the bet
that was good that was good that's not
enough that was good doesn't it feel
good enough right that was the best so
funny like you trust your like you your
your mental state you're like I'm gonna
put it in your hands and yeah my bad I
forgot your brain like I can't handle I
don't like when people like I guess I
prefer not the best that's why but I
would like if I was fighting and someone
was yelling you know you do this you're
the battle be like I'm not I don't
handle well how do you like how do you
handle that like are you comfortable
with people telling you the best I hate
being told she's gonna bring a big gold
shiny thing that says that she actually
is the best has one I think um the
difference between this last fight and
the one before that is that you know I
had like
he said I have the proof right here like
I don't need to you know tell myself in
order like so many times in order to
just believe it and this kind of like
but is it real you know kind of thing
the the first the first title fight was
was like that I had to just keep saying
it until it became a reality but this
time I was is right here so I don't and
that was the fear of just being like not
having to earn that confidence you know
I felt like well I already got it so but
I have to like not forget that I had to
keep earning it and have to keep you
know it maintaining it yeah it has that
like are you able to kind of process
that and be like I'm the champ and I
deserve to be the champ are you sitting
there like questioning like oh I don't
know but I haven't fought this person
under these circumstances and but you
know what I mean yeah I think every
every fight is um is a different fight
in its uh yeah it's always up for grabs
so every time you step in that cages is
50/50 you know anything can happen now
the targets on your back you know a long
time you're chasing something but now
when you have it everyone is gunning for
you
that would destroy me it's weird it's
definitely um you could see rose asking
herself is she the best and questioning
questioning yourself even after the
first fight it was still just a question
of a my other best time on the best and
then after the second fight it's turned
into nope I'm the best I'm the I'm she's
the best 13 she knows it she's the best
there is now now now it's up to us to
convince her she's not the best unless
she is going to earn the belt again we
write will write it on the board this
time but that's the game play we should
put like a time limit on we should stop
telling you did you guys go away after
you wanted you do anything fun go on
vacation or did you go anywhere we
married and we planted our garden that
was cool we haven't we haven't we
haven't yeah not yet no I'm not are you
waiting for something or you just you
haven't done there's like I just feel
like right after the fight there's so
much like physical
and mentally emotionally everything
happening and you see is a second to
process it plus we just like being home
anyways because like I don't know taking
away like I feel like vacation you have
to take a vacation after a vacation
because you just spent all this energy
going somewhere else that's not your
place you know what I mean like and
we've seen so many cool places that the
best places is home yeah do you like
doing the garden Yes Man yes like up
until we started doing this one no of
course no I love the whole time we've
been in dirt with worms and plant and
stuff lately we've we built like a
raised garden bed then we've got a bunch
of different things in right now and
it's um it's been yeah it's it's that's
what we're looking forward to most about
even being here in New York is we go
home tomorrow and like today and
tomorrow we get to get back into it
Rose I want to ask you to do you not
like being in here I know you said you
were tempted it wouldn't cut URI were
you on the bus when Connor did what he
did
mm-hmm well you did it mess you up
mentally where you thought you might not
fight how did that affect you um I mean
you can just kind of tell by my
performance you know everything I said
after in the press conference it's kind
of like you know does my feelings on the
issue and um it just sucks because
that's the question that's always gonna
be asked especially throughout the day
you know and it's like look what I did
well here's why because you said you
were getting in and out of New York
we're going home tonight I'm wondering
do you not like being in New York um I I
think it's a man every time I come here
from home yes so it's anywhere anywhere
you are yeah anywhere I am but uh
definitely New York is probably I say is
there there's better you know I I think
I like the Vegas is probably my
favorites big city but New York I think
every time I come here it's super
inspirational just because of how the
city is even functions like every time I
come here I'm like how does this place
even work but it's it feels easy to kind
of get mixed up and lost here like even
here you're like no one gives a [ __ ]
about me it's a good place right yeah
it's for sewer no one cares yeah it's
it's a lot to take in here um I think
every time that I fought here it's
always been it's it's definitely like
the perfect place to make a great story
so
a lot of things to appreciate it about
it but at the same time it's also
something that you know I was born in
Milwaukee and they're just it's just
like a big you know city and it's
definitely not not as big as this and
it's a big concrete jungle and so I kind
of long and yearn for the outdoors and
stuff like that so it's definitely not
my natural I guess my place that I want
to be but at the same time I also have a
great appreciation for it and there's a
lot to be learned and and this is a
great place and and one one of the
things I love about New York is that it
just has the feeling of there's there's
always a great story to be told here
yeah Pat when a disruption on that level
happens like right before a fight do you
as like not only a partner but a trainer
like do you sit there and be like okay I
see what's happening here it's my job to
get rose back into the mental state
because this is a severe disruption for
any athlete instantly that's every time
us every time we whenever we go anywhere
for a fight any time some incident
happens that's the first thing that
comes to mind is all right how are we
gonna get rose how are we going to okay
what's the move now because as soon as
that and as soon as that happened of
course it was instantly we're leaving
tonight
right like instantly it was when you
know just as it was going on that's the
thought that was in my head was now this
is this is ridiculous how like not this
is here we made it here and now this
like the soul it's it's it's
automatically into it like I said it's
the mental it's the mental side with
Rose that's always that's always not not
that's always the part that we're
working on so of course as soon as that
happened it's not just roses I want to
leave sure I don't want to be here
either like this isn't the kind of party
that I showed up for right you know so
that's that and then you have to I'm
sure you start questioning the
organization as a whole like how can you
allow this to happen to us right well I
mean there's there's a million different
fingers that you can pull in every
different direction but we have to take
we take responsibility for that right
there in there for ourselves and what we
have to do like what we're here for a
mission of course everything is away
everything yes everything in the world
is gonna try to distract rose from the
print is gonna try to distract us as a
team from the mission at hand
and and and it's it's one of those like
the more you go down this way and the
more things try to stop you the more you
know that that's the direction you're
supposed to be going in because right
before it gets to it gets hardest right
before you in the board the level on the
game they said in Batman the night is
the darkest before the dawn
yeah after that happens you guys go back
to the hotel which one of you is talking
the other one down do you guys look at
each other and go okay what are we gonna
do or did somebody else come in and and
like how did you guys get yourselves
back focus cuz that was right before the
fight I mean two days before but we
really sleep I mean we didn't really
talk much you talk a little a little bit
it's there we have a mission to
accomplish we're here we're here to do a
job and there's nothing that skin
there's nothing that's going to there's
most likely nothing that's gonna stop us
from from accomplishing our mission and
that's what it was as soon as it went
down it's always it's always like that
it's always things things get they get
the their maximum hard right before it's
over like it gets the maximum toughness
right before you break through to the
next level and this was just this was
just another of course this happened of
course this happened in order to shake
rose up in order to throw rose off her
game so that she wouldn't be able to
accomplish the mission that her whole
life has been set out to do whatever it
is and and that's that's what happened
it happened right there it's like okay
that we're no longer this is in the game
we are we're we're in for a fight are
you guys still in Milwaukee well I was
gonna say it becomes fuel to the fire
then yeah right like it becomes like now
it's now we're doing it not as soon as
it happened we had more we rose had more
of a reason to get her message out there
in the world right
that's that as soon as that happened it
said okay you know what you are doing
the right thing you are on the right
path because your message does have to
get out there and of course evil in the
world is gonna try to stop rose from
from from promoting goodness as much as
she possibly can do you have people send
you one and you become higher-profile do
you find that people coming out of the
woodwork like people you haven't seen in
20 years or 15 years and sometimes
people who don't want to see there's a
little bit of that you know but luckily
like I don't I don't really
read messages on social media that much
so but that's where the majority of a
lot of that stuff is so it's just like I
just don't have time for that man I'm
just
you probably save yourself a lot of
headaches because it can be like oh yeah
yeah like doing yeah harder you got
impressed those low kids right you know
time for social media commenting on all
the videos yeah ten different accounts
are all saying nice [ __ ] great I guess
that's gotta be part of it though right
that's part of the mental training is to
get I mean social media in this day and
age is a huge distraction for you guys
right it really is um it's it's a great
tool but man and with any tool can be
misused and I think that I don't know
just a lot of the just a lot of the
content out there there's so much
quantity and not a lot of quality so
that's why it's like man I just it's
just hard to let and and it's still like
it still traps me that's another little
trap you know I'll just be like damn
what am i doing scrolling again delete
that place I probably Instagram is
probably the most deleted and uploaded
yeah what do you do after you win the
championship like what's it like now all
the hard work has paid off we were
successful it's done like how do you
celebrate how do you unwind to anything
like anything well first off any like
lots of delivery because we we spent the
first couple days locked in my bedroom
like with like super paranoid about
everything like blind sure we we had
like pizza and delivery sushi delivery
sushi what you really are brave the most
yeah yeah we stayed we stayed inside for
like two weeks oh we just got delivery
just because it's all so much all at
once like let me just shut out or well
is it well it's because of healing tires
in the street and people wow the car in
reverse and stop crazy the week was very
like mmm it's gotta feel safe first I
can't my senses were so heightened for
so long and my adrenaline was taxed like
you know double the amount that it
should have been that like you know the
next you know I needed to decompress and
like like seriously just eliminate all
possible like you know scenarios that
capacitor that adrenaline high is not
ours it's weeks yeah for sure Wow oh man
we still on it yeah you don't like so
depending on the fight you know some
some fights it's it's worse than
sometimes it's better like you know
certain fights like after the first
fight with you wanna I didn't sleep for
probably a few days you know like maybe
three or four days I'm sure we just got
over the knockout like we're like last
week so we're on to the new fight now
yeah well are you easily distracted like
are you like are you are you like your
is your mental state when you feel right
kind of fragile like this can throw me
or that when I'm right no nothing
nothing can like I'm in my bubble I
barely even see anybody you know but
this last one I felt like I saw
everybody I was fee I was totally on
manual and totally like not on autopilot
like that's why I feel like sometimes it
was on autopilot and you know you kind
of just switch back and forth between
the two gears but almost the entire you
know the almost like the majority of the
fight was done manually and like making
decisions like conscious is that very
good that's bad it's very difficult I
mean yeah well it's bad angular it's bad
because of course you want to fight to
be on autopilot like the first fight
which she was just sold out completely
the same time it's also good to not be
another fight to know that you can
manually get hard
like the first fight she was on another
level no one in the world would have
been able to touch it that night the
second fight
she was very conscious the entire time I
mean with the UFC actually had no and
that's happening like just watching her
like I even told him before like in the
locker room I was like it's not turning
on the UFC he was like oh when your
training is right whenever I don't know
it's just sometimes it happens most
times it happens it sometimes it just
does and you have the entire training
camp was an auto pod this is this was a
very tough training camp every day was
was a I don't feel right every day
throughout the entire training camp was
something's just not right it's not
turning off I don't feel fast I don't
feel strong it was every day like that
so like I said we that's what started
the building up and then if that's what
consisted of the breaking down and then
we get all the UFC has it on film where
she's pacing back and forth and then she
walks up to me she says it's not turning
on with the most scared look on her face
it's not turning has that been released
that footage one clip where I saw where
it was after where I told Trevor that it
wasn't turning on man and he's like
don't worry about like he hung me or
whatever but the one that you were
saying that talking about I haven't seen
that but she says it's not turning on
and had the look of I mean just to be -
I have to I have to step out of the
coaches role for a split second and
after it was very emotional for me sure
to see Rose knowing that she's about to
get into a fight just to see the look in
her eye man I mean total confidence but
at the same time something's wrong
something doesn't feel right and it was
right then in there at that moment that
I had to fall into my own zone and say
hey girl turned on the whole training
camp
what do you you've been on this entire
time on man it was like a little bit
like I felt like towards the end of the
training camp that's when it like it it
was it was there was like just that we I
think like after that
I my adrenaline spiked prior to and then
so it just like that that extra little
no ID rainylin and I was saving for the
fight it was okay then you know I'm
running on some extra booster gears in
the back but they don't know that's the
important thing I've been times where
I'm scared in front of the car it's a
different day I'm going to get punched
but I mean I'm scared to perform and I'm
afraid or I but they don't know it right
so a lot of times I have to remember
like whatever I'm feeling they don't
know it so they're gonna react to me as
if I'm silly concentrate sometimes
people certain people do know you know
um certain people like even Heidi Dean
from the EOC like she's like oh she
calls it Rose mode you know like and
like during fight week I kind of just
get really quiet out and talked to
nobody like cuz I don't see nobody like
it's just I'm just in my zone and I
don't know if she like she didn't say
anything about Rose mode this time but
um I'm wondering everybody was saying
you didn't see everybody saying when you
didn't look like as you walked through
everybody as the champion as you walk
past and we're looking anymore they all
look over at me like man was going every
fights different so you can't be like
you know I don't know you don't know you
never know for sure until it acts the
moment of truth right but but there's
little there's little feelings of when
you there are so many variables that go
into it when you win a championship
fight while you're off afterwards are
you going like holy [ __ ] I'm
indestructible like I can't now I don't
but like you know yes it's a very it's a
very gratifying feeling but at the same
time it's like man I I feel like I could
have did better though you know it's
like it's a double-edged sword and and
and and there's only so many fights
where where you can do that for you know
like to have a five-round war like man
that takes a toll on your body in your
mind and spirit so it's like man I was
you know that I don't know it's it's a
double-edged sword basically it's very
gratifying but at the same time it's
also like taking I'm the highest
percentage finish like rate in the
strawweight division like I'm a finisher
like to not finish a fight it's it's
like I don't know I felt like damn that
got away from me you know I
so at the same time but yes I'm very
grateful for it you know I like it was a
very it was a huge accomplishment for me
but it's just something about something
about finishing your face great you need
fights like that you need you need
fights where everything doesn't
necessarily go your way and you have to
manually fight this person because it
takes a wait after a while fighting
becomes uninteresting in the middle of a
fight like you can man this is how many
morons at the same time yeah like I
don't mean to cut you off but and then
the other the other there's a lot of
things that are very gratifying about it
though like leading up to the fight Mike
Mike Brown said you know we want to see
what happens in a five-round fight and
the true champion wins in a five-round
fight that's what happens so a part of
me even like throughout the training
camp I was like man I really want to
like get a rear naked choke because
that's my favorite submission but at the
same time part of the you know hearing
them say five-round fight and real true
champion go five rounds all right gonna
go five rounds see whatever sorry when
you're choking somebody really is it
hard to let go it seems like it'd be so
much fun no it's it at once you like
your whole body is like just like
waiting for the tears you know so so
when you feel that it's but as you're
squeezed I don't know it's it's hard to
describe it's definitely like one of the
most I'd say is I don't know I feel like
it's better than a knockout because you
feel like it's like the ultimate feeling
of control when you when you've fully
dominated somebody like if you if you
rear naked choke somebody they've made
so many mistakes prior to now if you
submit somebody period like you get
knocked you can kick someone in the head
knock them on everybody thinks of that
people mad not like but but to jump in
the it to punch someone in the head and
knock them out they could want to
continue fighting but they just can't
use my brains all scrambled to make
someone quit that's the ultimate that's
that's right that's a conscious decision
that's the right they're like okay I'm
being [ __ ] strangle I can't stop this
and they're giving themselves to you so
yeah I choose to refuse to give up i'm
jamaica body
or a little Aisha a low kick finish a
body shot finish or submission and
there's no getting lucky there's no
lucky oh yeah I got one strike in and
you have to know in this one but you
know if you tap you quit that's just
another word nobody likes hearing that
but it's the truth if you lose a fight
to a low kick you quit too low case if
you lose a fight to a body shot because
you didn't get up you were conscious the
entire time you chose not to get up now
I totally get that getting punched in
the stomach sometimes can make you oh
yeah you're dying but it's still choice
as long as you're awake it's still a
choice so so rear naked choke someone is
way better than high cakey someone
because you know that not they quit on
you I made you give up I made you quit
yeah I guess so as opposed to an
involuntary thing where you went to
sleep on the floor right don't take a
head kick it what I would like
physically I think it's just because
like when it when it happens you barely
even feel it like you know like I don't
know just you don't like it man you just
what everything fires up in your whole
body so it's like that physical feeling
but but I think it just happened so fast
that you're not really you know
conscious so up for it like for me at
least like when I landed a head kick on
Michelle like I kind of blanked out like
the the couple thing is prior to it
landing even though I saw it as like saw
it happen I didn't feel it happen so
it's just kind of do you think that the
the mental stress of this stuff is
talked about enough because I mean and I
just started it just based on what we're
talking about today because like Ronda
Rousey
for example she said what like a week
ago she finally talked about how she had
cried like for like two years straight
after dealing with her losses and
clearly you know doesn't really like
talking about him to this day and you
know when an outsider sees that it's
like what's the big deal I like it when
you lose but like talking to you guys
it's like there's a lot yeah clearly a
lot more to it than I think that losing
in a UFC and yet losing sucks but losing
in a USC on the highest like it's just a
different level of like when you when
you climb the ladder so fast like the
way she did and then like to fall from
that high that's that's tough I would
think I would just imagine I don't know
I'm not in her shoes but I just would
imagine that's in every fighter though
losing losing so I can distract losing
when you're in the UFC means that you're
losing against one of the greatest
fighters on the planet at that point in
time and if you loosen them that should
be alright but losing sucks man but if
you but the thing some fighters can
rebound and fight again and other
fighters it's like it defines who you
are
yeah Who I am has been removed as things
outside you know that's why it's great
isn't as this is that's why I say this
is extra this is I don't you got that
yeah you just gotta it's gotta be a
healthy relationship this is that's why
I say this is like a having a
relationship with somebody right like
you gotta have a healthy curiosity to
know that you're the best not this like
need to know that you're the best
because at some point you know
something's gonna be better than me you
know I know that like everybody's got a
time limit everybody is you know we're
all we're all the same we're all human
so we all can achieve different things
and we're all unique but at the end of
the day we all have flaws and they're so
to me it's it's to know that you're not
perfect and that's okay that's a nice
little garden outside of the garden your
lives are very different than mine
sometimes you listen to people talk to
you like their existence is completely
the opposite we're all unique but at the
same time world we all like we all have
flaws like Jim uses fertilizer for
different reasons throw in but also that
fight was that was the best you honor
yes what yeah we've watched the fight
this is what we do after the fight we go
home when we watch it over and over
again so the pay-per-view points are
going up because I keep buying I keep
buying it and if anyone out there who's
gonna watch it again watch the fight
watch it again and just watch you on it
don't watch rose watch you wanna and
then try to imagine who the hell could
have survived five rounds of that
especially after like after a loss like
that you know so for her to come back is
it's pretty commendable I think you know
I mean she's still out there just you
know she doing crazy whatever topping
you
I gave her credit though like closely
paws was one of the things that mean to
fall off the top of the ladder the way
that she did and to go back and reinvent
herself and to come back usually stop
there something like that they come back
and they're never the same again she
came back and she wasn't the same she
was more ferocious like that that's very
very unique that's why she was the
reigning champ for also long because she
was able to take a knockout go back
change some things up and come back even
more ferocious than she was previous to
that knockout like that's why you want
is one of the greatest of all time how
is and then how have you been we have to
wrap up stroller because we have know
you guys have a lemon we have it a guest
wait what how about sponsorships and
stuff like that
that's been coming to you kind of or no
um little bit here and there where we're
in talks with some people you know but
it's I mean do you want more of it is it
something that money yes yeah I don't
know we were talking about social media
before I don't know if you've ever seen
it do you get offended when people
decide to make photo shops either
placing your head on Jimmy Orton's body
you know everybody like kind of makes
jokes about like Trevor and I my coach
my boxing coach like looking this thing
because we had same haircut we both like
Anna shape the same so yes I'm kind of
used to it I imagine she would yeah I
always feel like I look a lot better so
you do kind of you you want some more if
they come along Jimmy it's probably nice
to have the extra are you gonna write a
book want to write a book is your I've
talked to you many times your life story
is interesting yeah I've thought about
it um you know I keep a journal so I try
and you know keep keep note of like
interesting things that have like
there's so many little things that
happen throughout like our trips and
days that are just ridiculous and so you
know I trying up I think I'm gonna work
on that yeah yeah or send someone over
whoever wants to write a book story this
way where you get a guy who who you talk
to are you talking into a recorder and
they put it together into your story
there are guys who do that let's do it
yeah you sure I mean there's a there's a
video that just came out Rose I mean
it's the journey or something like that
that's like it's like a little mini
documentary yeah it's like a long
50-minute video and it's great and it
talks about our relate it starts off
with Pat's career and then it kind of
goes into mine
halfway through and it's it's amazing
it's amazing well you're you guys did a
video where you did was that Habitat for
Humanity where you went over you did
something we doing over Indonesia yeah
and you had cut your hand and I'm like
that's that's what these guys do that I
just go out and build houses for poor
people yeah it definitely is
is really you know fun time I mean it
was it was very difficult but very
rewarding and like I said it was
definitely not not my place you know I
don't know if I'm if I want to go back
necessarily anytime soon but is like I
said it's another great story great like
learning experiences yes you're a nicer
person than I am you don't do have a
human certainly don't I sit in the first
class and I had people thrown out who
come up to me we were getting on a plane
where we coming from Vegas we'll get on
a plane and as you start walking through
first class this guy this kid goes
dog-rose and then heard his dad turns
around and goes holy [ __ ] he's just
flipping out he says he's from Denver
and he saw us at a Vietnamese place once
I saw you with Shevchenko and Saigon and
basil and I didn't talk because I wanted
to be respectful but I'm not gonna be
respectful this time who the hell is
Doug Rose and he points to the guy he's
like that's von Miller right there and
the guy pilot came back and put him off
the plane he said I'll go graciously he
was too excited to see Sun rose and
Farah and plus you know if you're in
coach and he make eye contact with the
person if they don't like you should be
dismissed I see
the plane you paid good money for that
seat you don't need them looking at you
no it was the other way around he was in
first class we were in coach my
apologies
the guy off the plane for stopping you
as you're walking out all my yeah just
two weeks I could we kept walking but he
just kept on going that's too much
that's Colorado's first UFC champion and
a guy turns around goes who is what
that's von Miller right then in the
attorney who hoping also quickly they're
like I didn't you know I didn't know how
to react to I wish I could go back in
time it's like you know just we're good
they just rushed you in on the back yeah
yeah we'll see him again there was there
was a comedian that didn't want people
in did sit and coach in first class they
had to rush him to the back that was you